so here is the big story that's sweeping
the nation
woodward book trump says he knew
coronavirus was deadly and
worse than the flu while intentionally
misleading americans i'm not going to
play any games i'm not even going to
bury the lead i'm going to go straight
down and show you the quote
i still like playing it down because i
don't want to create a panic
and there it is we're done thanks for
hanging out everybody we'll see i'm just
kidding
trump admitted to woodward on march 19th
that he deliberately minimized the
danger
i wanted to always play it down i still
like playing it down because i don't
want to create a panic i have tremendous
respect
for that what should you have done i
think you did the right thing
you say well i think that panic is our
worst enemy we talked about this a long
time ago
um you know whatever the virus whatever
the situation if people start freaking
out and buying all the toilet paper
there's gonna be issues
they were fighting over toilet paper and
you had trump saying things weren't that
bad
right so the question when they
basically when they told people not to
wear masks
so they didn't want to run on the masks
that's kind of where i start to wonder
okay i know you don't want to instill
panic but
how many lies is it okay to tell to
circumvent panic
i think the the i think a lot of the one
of the big reasons why they were saying
don't buy masks yeah i need a mess
because it was it was not necessarily
just about a run on the masks
it was about creating a panic convincing
people you needed a mask
would have them be like for what you
know and then they would panic in other
ways
people don't realize how uh you know i i
don't know if you remember all the memes
that came out
where people were like oh no the economy
and there was like the one where the
earth was blowing up i think elon musk
elon musk posted it it's like an
astronaut on the moon
and there was like a comet blasting
through the earth the earth was
exploding and he was like
the economy and there was one where
dinosaurs were like walking around and
meteors were falling down and the
dinosaurs were like the economy
the funny thing is people don't realize
what the economy means do you know you
know what the word economy means
eco something to do with the earth it
comes from the greek like
mia meaning household management i
learned that from a rap news video from
like 10 years ago
yeah anyway uh i'm pretty sure that's
correct uh oy corner mia or something
like that
and the general idea is that when people
are saying like the economy oh no
you're talking about quite literally the
organizational structure that guarantees
food
travels from the farm to the table and
when that breaks down
and it did what happened supply chain
disruption shortages people lose their
jobs
a lot of it had to do with the lockdown
for sure but we were seeing like dairy
farms just dumping all the milk we saw
farms just shoveling
everything into the dirt and that's why
the economy matters
so yeah trump did the right thing i read
this story and they frame it like he
intentionally misled
america americans come on man i mean you
can't tell
people everything it's not his job you
know we have secrecy
for a reason as much as it can become
dangerous i think
you have to you know we have walls
because you can't show everybody
everything you're doing
you know people make plans in private
because sometimes people want to walk
around naked in their house man
oftentimes and if you if you open
oftentimes i mean for real too you know
and if you open up the blinds you can
get in trouble it's true literally
it's illegal to expose yourself yes yes
so so we have blinds for that
i'm actually i lean very very much
towards transparency
i think in the past a lot of people
would say that i was like a transparency
absolutist but that's just not true
but i'm very very much for public
transparency in the sense
if it's happening in the public the
public has a right to know
there are there are private things
especially when it pertains and so that
this does include a lot of government
functions but i do draw the line at
if we just published everything that we
did that we
we wouldn't exist as a country no we'd
be undermined we would undermine
ourselves it's almost like
well our foreign adversaries would take
all the information use it
create data sets and you know machine
learning prediction models and they
would
undermine like yeah they would be able
to track and predict and just disrupt
literally everything we did we'd be
under complete control
and the monarchy never would have been
overthrown george washington was
oh totally totally into secrecy i mean
he was great at spying and
i mean i've watched uh national treasure
tell me more
with uh with uh nicholas casey i didn't
see it you didn't see it
it's the one where nicholas cage like
the founding fathers had like secret
gold or something hidden under
dc or whatever do they uh i was gonna
ask for a spoiler
like finds a secret book it's an old
there's two of them they need to make a
third one because it's really hokey and
hilarious
anyway but yeah yeah they definitely
look we've had code we've had
there's a reason why we want to conceal
information because information is
valuable
in this regard i think the issue is
could you imagine if trump came out and
said
we're all gonna die no it'd be crazy
they would they would be like trump
created a panic
of course there's nothing the man could
do or say
the best people still kind of panicked
but they didn't really panic
and that would have been devastating if
yeah if more than toilet paper were
the conspiracy people were on it they
like they already had
three months supply of toilet paper and
they were sitting there shining their
gun being like you know
y'all are late to the party they got the
toilet paper stocked up
let me read a little a little bit of
this just to get some more some more
context into what they're saying
they say president trump's head popped
up during a top-secret intelligence
briefing in the oval office on january
28th
when the discussion turned to the
coronavirus outbreak in china quote
this will be the biggest national
security threat you face in your
presidency
national security advisor robert c
o'brien told trump
according to a new book by washington
post associate editor bob woodward
this is going to be the roughest thing
you face matthew pottinger
the deputy national security advisor
agreed he told the president that after
reaching contacts in china
it was evident that the world faced a
health emergency on par with the flu
pandemic of 1918
which killed an estimated 50 million
people worldwide
10 days later trump called woodward and
revealed that he thought the situation
was far more dire
than what he had been saying publicly so
trump is candidly speaking to
journalists
they this was crazy to me they're they
did a poll
and they asked republicans how do you
like is is the number of deaths like
okay
in in terms of you know are you it's
it's hard to to uh
iterate properly i suppose but the idea
was are you
happy of you know with the job that was
done and they basically said we find the
amount of debt to be
acceptable in the in in the context of
we were told it was going to be like 6
million oh wow i
i remember i was doing videos and i was
like wow the new york times is
predicting could be from
like two to six million this is crazy
it's like a massive percentage of the
population blah blah blah
and then it turns out uh it's you know
we're in 180 something thousand
and that's horrifying and that's you
know it's really bad
but look at this trump was warned it
could be 50 million people it's crazy
worldwide it's it it's terrifying but
who who
like i get that you got to go worst case
scenario some people's jobs are to
you know extrapolate worst case scenario
and plan for the worst case scenario but
that will cause crazy panic
and they wanted him to do it because
that's that's a conclusion that's being
drawn here here's some quotes
you just breathe the air and that's how
it passed trump said in a february
seventh call
and so that's a very tricky one it's a
very delicate one it's also more deadly
than even your
strenuous flus this is deadly stuff the
president repeated for emphasis
at that time trump was telling the
nation that the virus was no worse than
a seasonal flu
predicting it would soon disappear and
insisting that the u.s government
had it totally under control it would be
several weeks before
he would publicly acknowledge the virus
was no ordinary flu
and it could be transmitted through the
air trump admitted to woodward on march
19th
is where he said i don't want to create
a panic aside from exploring trump's
handling
of the pandemic woodward's new book rage
covers race relations diplomacy with
north korea
and a range of other issues that have
arisen during the past two years
the book also includes brutal
assessments of trump's conduct
from former defense secretary jim mattis
former director of national intelligence
daniel coates and others
the book is based in part on the 18 on
the record interviews woodward conducted
with the president between december and
july woodward writes that other quotes
in the book
were acquired through deep background
conversations with people
in which information is divulged in
exchanges recounted without the people
being named
i'm not going to read through all of
this because the the the gist of the i
uh
you know i get we have the the gist of
things but i just got to point out man
you have you heard about some of the
things that trump has done recently um
some i enlightened me the uh israeli
peace deal yeah israel uae
yeah then there was the kosovo serbia
peace deal which include recognition of
israel
and now now he's going to be drawing
down our our troop numbers by about 2
000
in iraq back bringing them troops back
that's good right it's great dude that's
great
so what do you consider yourself
politically i'm very moderate i don't
think i don't play
party politics i just look for the
smartest guy in the in the
woman in the room and try and support
them you were saying like a week ago
that you didn't like trump you were like
no he's a bombast
he yells he says things like really
crude
you know and ups he he alienates people
by talking about dem the democrat
the democratic mayor is alienating 40
million people so that and that causes
anger amongst those people and then
that's not what we need right now
we need like cohesion yeah yeah
a lot of people who really support trump
will push back on that but i gotta tell
you man i've been in i've like
i've been in uber rides i've talked to
regular people
and i hear the same thing often they're
like i really like what he's doing for
the country but i wish he wouldn't tweet
so much
or i wish he would kind of chill out
things like that and it's tough
i i wonder if it's because he really
wants to fire up his really loyal base
yeah probably and keep keep that fire
burning yeah so he's very raw
or maybe it's just who trump is you know
he's just he's he is a
bombastic fella i i don't know people
people that know him say that he's
exactly like that in person
but it seems like a character no no you
know you know i think it's real
he did 18 on the record interviews with
woodward
he straight up was talking about
what he was doing what was going on he
was very candid and transparent
it was it's interesting because the the
intercept ran this wrote this article a
while ago saying
trump is the most honest the least
honest and the most honest present we've
ever had
good one and they mention it's because
trump will lie about a lot of things
like uh for example he tweeted i never
called john mccain a loser
but he did he tweeted john mccain you
should be in articles like donald trump
john mccain is a loser
he wasn't referencing mccain's service
though and i think that's
what he was i don't i don't necessarily
want to give trump the benefit of the
doubt like i can't assume what his
intent was he straight up said
i never called him a loser he did and
it's it's weird silly things like that
where it's like is that even that
important
you could have just been like look i
called the guy a loser because he lost
in 2008 but i have nothing but respect
for his service
and oh he was literally calling him a
loser because he lost the election
exactly exactly
yeah so someone brought it up he was
being interviewed and he was like he's a
loser he lost
and then they're like he's a war hero
and trump was like nah he's not a war
hero he got caught
i prefer people who didn't get that's
brutal it is it is brutal
yeah but you know what there's a really
funny uh comment i heard where someone
said something like
people hated john mccain conservatives
hated john mccain more than they were
concerned about trump's
statements on like military service yeah
i don't know so like a big mccain fan
are you
did you like it no i'm not into war
mongers in general right yeah exactly
that guy's smiling smiling pictures he's
like we're gonna go blow stuff up
well i i would rather have somebody who
lies about tiny things than someone who
lies about big things like obama did
oh yeah absolutely the tpp doing it with
a smile
that's that can be much more insidious
but here's here's what basically what
the intercept brought up was trump
i love this interview he just announced
we're doing this big weapons deal with
saudi arabia and that was like
he just said it dude you know and he's
honest i mean he lie
is he honest or is he a liar or is it is
it both
he's not he's mostly mostly honest right
like these protests yes
i think he's mostly possible i think
that it's really hard to break down
but i think donald trump lies about some
of the stupidest things ever that he
should just
be upfront about right but then he's
really open and honest about a bunch of
other things which is
he not supposed to be i know like this
is crazy
they're dragging trump for being honest
with a journalist
this is nuts they they they complain
that he lies to journalists all the time
and you can't trust him then when he's
honest this is this what do they expect
yeah this is just people that want him
down
yeah well i'll tell you what man you
know my favorite thing about this
woodward
releases trump telling woodward that he
drank the kool-aid dude i wonder if he
even knows where
that's from drinking the kool-aid yeah
which is from the jonestown massacre
where yeah yeah yeah what's the guy's
name i don't remember like another guy's
name
i don't know i can look it up took them
all to jonestown and then had them all
drink
kool-aid laced with cyanide tearing
babies away from their mothers
that's nightmarish it really is yeah
yeah yeah i remember
that that happened in our lifetime right
like was it the 70s maybe
was town something maybe 1978 really
mm-hmm
november 18. of members of the
california-based people's temple cult
that was jim jones yeah johnstown i
didn't realize it was that long ago
what was that thing that happened in
like the 90s where they all thought they
were going to go on a spaceship or
something oh my gosh they still have
their website
up dude i remember that they have a
website from the super 90s
yes jones ride the tail hail bop i don't
know who it was
but their website they left two of their
members alive to maintain their website
i remember
reading wow this was yeah i'm gonna have
to look it up i don't remember
who it was or what cold they were you
said the name of the cult earlier what
whatever it was heaven's gate yeah i
think it was evans gate yeah let me see
if i can find the site i might tweet it
out
because i remember watching family guy
did an episode about it where like
meg joins a cult gate.com oh she
knows let me see if i can
hold on for the people that are
listening the context is that yeah
everyone's saying heaven's gate yeah is
that donald trump said to bob woodward
what is this this is an amazing 90s site
and i wish you guys could see my screen
throw it up it's got like a talisman and
it's moving and at the top
it says what's the website uh
heavensgate.com
we're going to heaven's gate guys it'll
be great for the record i don't think
you can ride the tail of a comment i
don't think so either
pull it up there it's a geocity site
dude wow
yeah you're welcome you guys made so
websites right i mean i i
used to i used to make flash websites i
used to actually do all the programming
in flash
and you're right it's hale bop yeah look
at that hail bop that's freakish
oh this is weird oh and all these people
are dead now
it's creepy except for the two who are
maintaining the website i guess as far
as i can tell they're okay
okay anyway anyway the context is it's
not
particularly relevant i guess where
drinking the kool-aid comes from but uh
it is a thing
and so so what happened is this is
actually i i think this is amazing
check this out from forbes wow no in
audio tape trump
rejects notion he has white privilege
good for you good sir
good for you trump i'm glad he's doing
this president trump flat out rejected
the notion he has benefited from white
privilege during an interview with
washington post reporter bob woodward
and then responded with contempt
according to audio clips reported by the
post wednesday
and we will play you the audio clip we
will play them for you because i love it
woodward conducted 18 hour market
interviews we know this
during one interview on june 19th as
protests broke out across the country
over george george floyd woodward asked
trump whether they both were isolated
and caged from understanding the anger
and pain of black americans
as two white men of the same generation
with similarly privileged upbringing
bringings
no trump said before responding in a
mocking tone you really drank the
kool-aid didn't you
i love it just listen you trump went on
expressing contempt wow
no i don't feel that at all trump went
on to touch economic statistics for
black americans pre-pandemic
including the low black unemployment
rate before repeating a commonly used
claim
that he's done more for the black
community than any president since
abraham lincoln
during a separate interview on race on
june 22 trump somewhat shifted his tone
acknowledging there was
systemic or institutional racism
everywhere but that there was probably
less in the us than most places trump is
right yeah i think you know what man
i really wish that he he was
less bombastic loud and abrasive
because i'm like he's saying populist
things that need to be said
that moderate regular people want to
hear we're bringing the troops back
okay this white privilege stuff is is is
is you know
no way you're drinking the kool-aid we
should talk about majority privilege
because i think
really yes it's the misnomer is that
they're making it a racial issue when it
comes down to the majority in the
country you're in
people that look like you and
unfortunately it seems to come down to
the way things look
or smell or there's a lot here to break
down but first
we are we are blessed with the actual
recording of
of what happened and hopefully you'll be
able to hear this properly but
let me ask you this yeah it is not
playing
let's try that again okay let's see if
this plays now
and we'll start this over hey but let me
ask you this
i mean we share uh one thing in common
we're white uh privileged who
my father was a lawyer and a judge in
illinois
we know what your dad did
and uh do you have
any sense that
that privilege has
isolated and put you in a cave
to a certain extent is it put me and i
think lots of white
privileged people in a cave and that we
have to
work our way out of it to understand
the anger and the pain particularly
black people feel in this country
do you no you've you really drank the
kool-aid didn't you you listened to you
wow no i don't feel that at all i love
that you really drank the kool-aid
didn't you
yes they did they all did they're losing
it
all right now listen there there is
something to this idea of white
privilege
but it's it's what you just mentioned
because we've we've talked about this
before it's it's majority privilege
if you're in china you are going to be
able to navigate the country much more
easily
knowing the language being easily
identifiable as chinese we don't call
that
chinese privilege in any country that
would be the case in fact in some
countries like notably in africa
you could you could literally be the
same ethnic background but
have a different tribe and then you have
tribal privilege it's
really just about the dominant group and
so what's happened is
this kool-aid drinking thing that's
that's happening and i'm glad to see
trump is pushing back on because people
are insane
it's it's it's in the us it's fair to
say
this country for a long time it's an
overwhelming white majority and still is
to this day
so there is something to what they're
pointing out but it is
extremely racist the way they're going
about it
sure if you have like what they call
like an anglicized name
then you're more likely to get callbacks
and stuff like that this is true
and and there have been actors who have
changed their name and made them more
like anglicized i think cal pen do you
know the actor
uh yeah right no no no no cal pen is
the guy from held in kumar oh okay
no no no i guess my short
he's the indian guy apparently his first
name that guy's awesome yeah he's cool
dude
he was also one house apparently his
name is kalpin like cal pen is one word
is his first name
so he changed it so that his name was
cal pen and got more call backs oh
there is something to familiarity the
problem i have with this
is that the conclusion they come to when
they talk about white privilege would be
like
the homeless guy you know sitting in his
own filth with no teeth
is privileged and has power and is an
oppressor
right over like a wealthy i don't know
like latino dude who's like working at a
law firm so it's
like there's two things going on at once
there's majority privileges
at work and then there's this coming out
of slavery thing 150 years ago where
people are being dumped like the
the african-american great-grandfathers
and stuff came
had no money no education they were at a
disadvantage
it's yeah yeah but it's it's more than
that too i mean yeah
so here's my problem and this is
actually let me preface this with the
context of what trump is saying right
here and why i really really like it
i can't believe that i have to actually
look to a republican president
for accurately giving us the space to
deal this problem
in a legitimate way especially when
a lot of conservatives wouldn't even
agree with me on many of these issues
you can't have these conversations with
the left they've determined already that
you're white you're an oppressor
and it's all this ridiculous culti
racist nonsense
so here's the things that i i've
identified and and i think this is fair
and and and makes a lot of sense there's
historical racism
it this used to be what was systemic
racism but they've changed the
definition so i don't even know what
people are talking about anymore
the general idea being that we so it
wasn't just about
ending slavery and then having a bunch
of people with inherited wealth
and a bunch of people with nothing it
was that after that you had the
democrats
working on all of these restrictions and
you know the jim crow era and things
like this segregation
that actually created a lot of problems
and made things worse
it actually made sure that not only did
they have no wealth but they had no
access to any of the existing
infrastructure
and that was that was the democratic
party you know the clan for instance
when they went around and the horrible
things the clan did and then finally we
shut them down and got rid of them
seems like the republicans had a lot a
lot going on shutting down
the racists thanks for checking out this
clip from the tim cast
irl podcast we do the show live monday
through friday at 8pm so come back to
check us out when we go live
don't forget to subscribe hit the like
button hit the notification bell
and we are also available on all podcast
platforms for free
if you want to listen to us there thanks
for hanging out and we will see you all
next time
you